the wildfires are rapidly moving from
one place to another and consuming
almost everything in this area in the
argentine province of coriendes
and firefighters are also moving fast
trying to burn a control line that will
slow down the advance of the flames
what they are doing is burning a line
that will force the fire to slow down
and then they will attack it with water
there's already a group working inside
we have to stop it before it reaches the
road because if it passes there there
are thousands of hectares of pine trees
and it will get even worse
over 800 thousand hectares have already
been destroyed and with it livestock
grains and wildlife
this is an area that generally sees
abundant rainfall but strong winds lack
of humidity and drought are making it
easy for fire like this one to spread
all across the province and an average
of around 30 000 hectares of land are
burning every day
also at risk are 12 000 hectares of
marshlands in iwera
the area is a natural reserve where
kaiman's amphibians another 300 species
of birds are being affected
firefighters from brazil and other parts
of the country like buenos aires have
come here in an effort to prevent the
fires from causing even more damage
is in charge of the firefighters that
have come from buenos aires
the only thing we can't control is
nature so you need to control everything
else corientes is lacking resources they
don't have the equipment they need they
have great people but they're not
prepared they need pickup trucks
firefighting kits uniforms among other
things
he says he has lost almost everything he
owns most of his land was burned by the
fire and like many others is currently
in debt
sometimes i don't want to continue but i
have to because what am i going to tell
my family i have a family of 60 people
19 work with me where's my family going
to work there's no work here aside from
this
rain is crucial at this point to prevent
the fires from spreading to other
provinces but heavy rainfall is not
expected until march
a long wait for those involved in the
daily fight against the flames
there
is argentina